would someone like to give me a
suggestion
and i've got three in my head so
whatever you've got you're probably
gonna hear one of them
can someone give me a suggestion for
what we might be able to do here
remember we're trying to find a
and b right what might be something that
could be
helpful friend what do you think
write a little subheading which is
method one
compare coefficients
this wasn't going to be the one i did
first for ren but you chose it so we'll
run with it okay
so what's written talking about uh on
the left hand side oh so let me start
that again on the right hand side you've
got an x term
and you've got a constant term on the
left side if we did expand
you would get a bunch of x terms and a
bunch of constant terms
we've done this back in complex numbers
right we can compare the real
and imaginary components on one side of
an equation versus the other
and you can gain insight that way often
so let's have a go at this in order to
do this comparison
my left hand side's not quite in the
right state is it right because i'm like
oh i have many x's okay
so can someone tell me how many x's will
i get on the left hand side
after expansion
i've got a lots of x here and i've got b
lots of x here
so therefore in one fell soup i could
say i've got that many x's
is that okay just done the expansion
that's the x terms what about the
constant terms what do you see
maybe another color might help you out
here right there's a constant
right there no x's and there's another
one
so looks to me after expansion i'm going
to get negative a
plus two b there's my constant term
right there
that's equal to eight x plus seven so at
this point i would say
as foreign has suggested by comparing
coefficients
by the way as we've said many times
please tell me what you're doing don't
just jump to
some new lines of working at this point
without saying like i'm taking a left
turn i'm doing something different now
give me some words to explain i'm going
to do my x terms then i'm going to do my
constant terms so here come my x's
a plus b equals
8. uh negative a
plus two b equals
seven x terms constant terms
at this point what have we done we
turned some weirdo looking problem
into simultaneous equations i am so
confident you can take it from here i'm
not even going to finish this because
don't forget we actually already know
what the answers were but you can go
ahead and do your maybe three or four
lines of working
what would be your first line by the way
just having a look at how they've been
set up
i'm probably going to add them yes so if
i add these two equations my a's cancel
i get 3b
equals 15. so b is going to be equal to
5 which indeed what
and you'll get a from that is that okay
so that was method one
would someone like to suggest to me oh i
better wipe all this off
uh if we go back to this line right here
would someone suggest to me something
else we could do
method two
any takers what do you recommend um we
can
substitute positive one and negative two
uh uh separately
i'm glad you said separately okay so
what's what's morgan saying just in case
you didn't catch it
if you have a look back at this line
here just look up for a second if you're
writing things
because you do need to um focus quite
closely if you're looking at this line
here
right what we did in this instance was
we expanded and then created a system of
simultaneous equations right but we
actually don't need to create
separate equations if we know how to use
this thing appropriately for example
what we're really doing is trying to get
from like one equation
with uh two unknowns two equations with
two unknowns eventually you get
one equation with one unknown great but
getting
one equation with one unknown this is
not the only way to do it
i could just get rid of a this is the
only place it appears do you see that
i can get rid of a by choosing an
appropriate value of
x that makes sense and the appropriate
value as morgan just stated
is the one that makes this factor here
collapse so if i say
let's call this method two substitution
if i choose x equals one
my a term disappears because it's really
a times
zero so what do i get left with b
times have a look three
now i substitute into the left hand side
i have to substitute into the right hand
side
as well so what do you get eight
eight lots of one plus seven sure enough
is
15. does that sound familiar
it should it's it's what we got
immediately after this line by doing
elimination right
so you've got your value of b um and
then you can get your value of a
from there that's method two
choose a substitution oh what's the
other substitution by the way
negative two would do it that would make
your b term disappear
and uh you would get what we get let's
see here
negative three a equals in this case
uh yeah this is negative 16 plus
seven which is negative nine you divide
through by negative three
sweet that's what we expected okay now
um
this one is a bit harder to guess but i
am going to give you
this last one because once people learn
it sometimes it becomes their favorite
and it's sort of like a hybrid between
method one and method
two that's why i said kind of like two
and a half methods before
there's a name for this but i actually
don't like it so i'm just going to leave
this for a second i'm going to show you
the method
and then i want to see if you can come
up with a better name for this okay
i'd like you to just pen down look up
for a second
i'd like you to rewind a step method one
and method two they picked up from this
orange star
right here we looked at this equation
and then we went
and did stuff to it to get a to get b
okay
this third method actually goes one line
back it's over here
okay it says well you know what we can
actually
make this easier to work with if we
actually kind of
return back to having less factors in
here
let me see if i can make this a little
more obvious you would not normally
write this line which i'm about to ask
you to write and i'm going to write in
your working but you need to see it so
that you know
what the next line is standing on okay
this thing here
i could write as two separate fractions
that's where i'm going isn't it like
two partial fractions okay so write this
long line with me
from here i can say
a lots of x minus one on
x plus two x minus one
hold on sorry take it back have i gone
back to the wrong line
i have gone back to the wrong line it's
the one before let's try that again
right here i've done what we always tell
you not to do
in your solutions which is draw arrows
all over your answers okay let's get
back to that very top line
okay what i'm going to do is take this
top line i'll rewrite it over here just
for the sake of clarity
and what i'm going to do is try and get
rid of
one of the fractions in order to make it
easier to do this substitution thing we
did in method two
how am i going to do this well one at a
time i'm going to multiply
by a particular denominator in order to
get rid of the appropriate fraction
so for example let's contemplate what
will happen if i multiply
everything through by x plus 2
i'm going to multiply everything through
by x plus 2.
what do i get well this just turns into
a you around with that
it's not too controversial this turns
into
x plus 2 on x minus 1. nothing cancels
because the denominator and the fact the
numerator don't
cancel what do i get on the right hand
side
yeah this guy is going to cancel so that
x plus 7 that you told me still stays up
in the numerator
and on the denominator x minus 1.
okay now i said this is kind of a hybrid
with method two right
in method two what we did uh morgan
suggested we choose an appropriate value
of x
to substitute because it's the same
question it's gonna be the same
values look at what happens when i put x
equals negative 2
into here x equals negative 2.
what happens to the a
nothing it's just there what happens to
this term
poof it's gone on the right hand side i
do need to do some
operations that's fine uh does this
sound familiar negative 16 plus seven
on negative two negative one sorry
negative two minus one
right so you're back at you're back at
this situation aren't you
right this one here but you've already
done the division because it's kind of
baked in to your original fraction
so you get what do we say negative 9 on
negative 3 and then off you go
okay that got me a
morgan do you have a question or a
suggestion yes go ahead
um because in method three since the
first uh second line we substitute a
random value into our
equations i mean listen in that cases
identity yes we just substitute a random
value
for method two when we do substitution
we've
defined the star on the left-hand side
we can also substitute random values
into it that we can do
that's basically the same idea
are you talking about why why fractions
appeared over here oh why we
use the fraction formula sure so
i instead of using this line uh in some
senses it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what i'm trying to do
is actually get the a
like i have to in this in all of these
other situations i get a
with a coefficient at the front i know
eventually i will need to divide by this
coefficient so why not use the form
where i have already divided
by the coefficient do you see that so
it's just like oh why did i
turn this into multiplication to undo i
have to go back and divide
when the original thing had division
already in it so just use the division
that's already there
i hope you can see all of the methods
are the same in the end but it's like
well which one
sits nicer in my brain let me complete
it
because i've got a but i haven't got b
from here
i might instead also multiply by what do
we do this time x plus 2
let's do x minus 1. here's my
term on the left what's my term on the
right
i'm multiplying my x minus 1 remember i
should just get
b that's the whole point of what i'm
after and then on the right hand side i
get left with
this x plus
2. is that all right and i will just do
the same thing i will choose an
appropriate value of x we've already
chosen this before
in this case it's x equals 1. that will
make my
a fraction disappear it will leave
my b term unscathed i really should say
zero plus b
okay and then on the right hand side
again does this sound familiar because
we've done the same arithmetic
three times now uh 15
on three and we got the five that we've
already seen from the beginning
okay so this method of partial fractions
phenomenally useful we haven't quite got
to the end of it yet because what i'm
dealing with so far
is you can see here we've got what we
call linear
sets of partial fractions sometimes you
get something
which you cannot break any further right
you don't get x plus two x minus one
uh can someone give me say a quadratic
that you couldn't break apart you
couldn't factorize
it's not hard to think of one okay so
you might have
uh x squared say plus one
don't ever think of guys you're like oh
i really i'm in calculus land
i would really not prefer to add in some
complex numbers here okay
um complex analysis actually is its
whole own branch of mass which we're not
really touching
so this in the real world i am treating
as
unfactorizable it's just done right um
we are going to get to the point later
on where
you don't just get a constant at the top
you're actually going to get a linear
factor right so we'll come to that a bit
later on but you've already got the
basic handle of it and we're going to
start
on these questions shortly